Hey! Guess what? DLM model lifestyle just made 100,000 subscribers and it is all
thanks to you guys. so from the bottom of
my heart, right there, I just want to say
thank you so much for supporting my
channel. it really means a lot and so I
thought it's a good idea to come back to
where it all started. now some of you
that's been here with me from the
beginning will recognize this place.
this is where I shot my first video
have you ever wondered what an
international models lifestyle is really
like? what is their secret in health and
fitness? to keep a model body? what is
their best beauty and grooming hacks to
always look their best? and what is their
best tips on style?
hi I'm Daniel Maritz and this is DLM
model lifestyle, subscribe to check
out my new videos on YouTube.
yeah that
was my first ever video now if you're
new to my channel this is what you've
been missing out on so far
hey thank you so much for being on this
journey with me so far!
and a special thanks to my wife Nikita
you're amazing I love you and thank you
for supporting me with this channel